now and thank you for joining us at 11
o'clock i'm denise valdez and i'm brian
loftis a unlv student still reeling from
a terrifying encounter she says a man
broke into her dorm room happened in the
middle of the night nearly a week later
unlv says it is making changes to make
sure that students are safe victoria
saha joins us live on campus tonight
with a story you will only see on 8 news
now
a quiet night on campus turned into
something you could only imagine seeing
in a movie coming face to face with an
intruder is something eliza miller never
thought would happen all while sleeping
inside her dorm room
unlv senior eliza miller now uses a
towel as an extra layer of protection
around her windows
she's not taking any chances after going
through a terrifying ordeal i was deep
asleep so i open my eyes and then i see
like i feel the breeze of cold air like
on my face
and i have glass shards all over my hair
my face a man had broken into her dorm
window using two huge rocks miller had
no time to do anything but run when i
saw him step onto my bed that's when
like i went out the intruder tried
getting into other rooms and was
eventually arrested on the roof nearly a
week later miller feels more needs to be
done for student safety on campus i'd
rather have it looking like a prison
than risk or safety since the break-in
unlv says they are in the process of
replacing all first floor dormitory
windows with shatter resistant materials
the assistant director of residential
life sent out this email to students
living in miller's building saying there
was no theft or any harm done to a
student i was like three to four inches
away of almost like dying or even you
know like having my face completely
smashed in miller says she is still
waiting on an apology from residential
life unlv responded with a statement
saying counseling is available for
students impacted adding that housing
staff will get additional security
training this summer
there were surveillance cameras right by
the window where this incident happened
i did ask campus police police excuse me
if those cameras were active during that
time i have yet to hear back for them as
for miller she says last night was her
first time sleeping back in her dorm
room and it was a rough night she was
having nightmares reporting from the
unlv campus tonight victoria saha live
local now